A medida que fluye por recodos,
se deforma y se agrieta.
Yo estudio estas impresionantes dinámicas del hielo
que están situadas en uno de los entornos físicos más remotos
que quedan sobre la Tierra.
Trabajar en glaciología ahora mismo es como empezar por la primera planta
en Facebook en los años 2000.
(Risas)
Nuestra capacidad de sobrevolar los mantos con aviones y satélites
está revolucionando la glaciología.
Está suponiendo para la ciencia
lo que los smartphones para las redes sociales.
Los satélites proporcionan abundantes observaciones
que nos revelan continuamente hechos novedosos acerca de los mantos de hielo.
Por ejemplo, tenemos datos del tamaño del manto de hielo de Groenlandia
de cada mes desde 2002.
Pueden mirar aquí abajo en la pantalla
para ver cómo avanzan los meses y los años.
Pueden ver que algunas áreas del manto de hielo se derriten
o pierden hielo en verano.
En otras cae nieve
o recuperan hielo en invierno.
No obstante, este ciclo se eclipsa por una velocidad total de pérdida de masa
que habría desconcertado a los glaciólogos hace 50 años.
Nunca pensamos que un manto podía perder masa en el océano con esta rapidez.
Desde que empezaron estas mediciones en el 2002,
el manto ha perdido tanto hielo
que si pusiéramos toda esta agua encima de nuestro continente más pequeño,
hundiría Australia hasta las rodillas.
¿Cómo es posible?
Pues, debajo del hielo tenemos el lecho de roca.
Hemos utilizado un radar para ver las colinas, los valles,
las montañas y las depresiones sobre los que fluye el hielo.
Bajo el manto de hielo, canales ocultos del tamaño del Gran Cañón
encauzan hielo y agua hacia el océano lejos de Groenlandia.
El motivo por el que el radar puede revelar el lecho de roca
es que el hielo es totalmente transparente para el radar.
Pueden hacer un experimento.
Váyanse a su casa y pongan un cubito de hielo en el microondas.
No se derretirá,
porque las microondas o el radar
atraviesan directamente el hielo sin interactuar con él.
Si quieren derretir su cubito de hielo, tienen que mojarlo,
porque el agua se calienta fácilmente en el microondas.
Este es el principio en el que se basa el diseño del horno microondas.
El radar puede ver el agua.
Y el radar ha revelado una inmensa piscina de agua líquida
escondida bajo mi compañera Olivia,
siete plantas bajo sus pies.
Aquí, ha usado una bomba
para sacar un poco de esta agua a la superficie del manto de hielo.
Hace solo seis años no teníamos ni idea de que este glaciar acuífero existiera.
El acuífero se formó
cuando la nieve se derrite al sol veraniego
y se filtra hacia abajo.
Se recoge en enormes piscinas.
Desde allí, la nieve actúa como un iglú,
aislando esta agua del frío y el viento arriba.
Así que el agua puede quedarse oculta en el manto de hielo
en forma líquida año tras año.
La pregunta es, ¿qué pasa después?
¿El agua se queda allí para siempre?
Podría.
¿O encuentra su camino para llegar al océano global?
Una posible manera para que el agua llegue al lecho de roca
y de allí al océano
es una grieta o una fractura en el hielo.
Cuando las fracturas se llenan de agua,
su peso las fuerza a penetrar a una profundidad cada vez mayor.
Así es cómo funciona el fracking
para extraer gas natural desde las profundidades de la Tierra.
Los fluidos bajo presión fracturan las rocas.
Solo se necesita una grieta para empezar.
Pues, recientemente hemos descubierto
que hay fracturas en el manto de hielo de Groenlandia
cerca de este acuífero glaciar.
Se puede sobrevolar la mayoría del manto de Groenlandia
sin ver nada,
ninguna fractura, nada en particular sobre la superficie
pero a medida que este helicóptero se acerca a la costa,
el camino que tomaría el agua al descender,
aparece una grieta
y después otra y otra.
¿Estas grietas están llenas de agua?
Y si es así, ¿a qué profundidad llevan esa agua?
¿Pueden llevarla al lecho de roca
y al océano?
Para contestar a estas preguntas,
necesitamos algo más que datos obtenidos por detección remota.
Necesitamos modelos numéricos.
Yo escribo modelos numéricos que funcionan en super computadoras.
Un modelo numérico es simplemente un conjunto de ecuaciones
que contribuyen a describir algo.
Puede ser tan sencillo como el siguiente número en una secuencia
--uno, tres, cinco, siete--
o puede ser un conjunto de ecuaciones más complejo
que predice el futuro
en base a condiciones conocidas en el presente.
En nuestro caso, ¿cuáles son las ecuaciones de cómo se rompe el hielo?
Bueno, los ingenieros ya tienen una idea muy clara
de cómo se fracturan el aluminio, el acero y el plástico bajo tensión.
Es un problema importante en nuestra sociedad.
Y resulta que las ecuaciones de los ingenieros
de cómo se fracturan los materiales
no se diferencian mucho de mis deberes de física.
Así que las tomé prestadas, las adapté al hielo
y obtuve un modelo numérico de cómo se puede fracturar una grieta
cuando se llena de agua del acuífero.
Es el poder de las matemáticas.
Nos puede ayudar a comprender los procesos reales de nuestro mundo.
Ahora les mostraré los resultados de mi modelo numérico,
pero primero debería señalar
que la grieta es cerca de mil veces más estrecha que profunda,
así que aquí en el panel principal,
hemos usado el zoom para que se vea mejor.
Pueden mirar el panel más pequeño a la derecha
para ver la escala real y lo alta y delgada que es la grieta.
A medida que el agua del acuífero cae en la grieta,
una parte de ella vuelve a congelarse en el hielo a 15º C bajo cero.
Es igual de frío que el congelador de sus casas.
Pero esta pérdida se puede superar
si la velocidad a la que fluye el agua del acuífero glaciar es bastante alta.
En nuestro caso lo es
y el agua del acuífero lleva la grieta hasta el fondo del manto de hielo
unos mil metros más abajo.
Desde allí, tiene el camino hecho para llegar al océano.
Así que el agua del acuífero es una parte
de los 3 mm de aumento anual del nivel del mar
que experimentamos como sociedad global.
Pero esto no es todo:
el agua del acuífero podría estar empujando por encima de su peso.
El hielo fluye de manera compleja.
En algunos sitios lo hace muy rápidamente.
Allí suele haber agua en la base del manto de hielo.
En otros sitios no tan rápidamente.
Normalmente, allí no hay presencia de agua en la base.
Ya que sabemos que el agua del acuífero llega a la base del manto de hielo,
la siguiente pregunta es:
¿Esto hace que el hielo mismo fluya más rápidamente hacia el océano?
Estamos intentando resolver los misterios ocultos en el manto de Groenlandia
para poder prepararnos mejor ante el aumento del nivel del mar.
La cantidad de hielo que ha perdido Groenlandia desde 2002
es solo una pequeña parte del que contiene ese manto de hielo.
Los mantos de hielo son máquinas inmensas y poderosas que funcionan a plazos largos.
En los próximos 80 años, el nivel global del mar aumentará por lo menos 20 cm,
tal vez hasta un metro
y quizás más.
Nuestra comprensión del futuro aumento del nivel del mar es buena,
pero nuestros pronósticos varian mucho.
Es nuestro trabajo como glaciólogos y científicos
reducir estas incertidumbres.
¿Cuánto va a subir el nivel del mar
y con qué velocidad va a hacerlo?
Necesitamos saber cuánto y cuan rápido,
para que el mundo y sus comunidades puedan prepararse
para el próximo aumento del nivel del mar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)